and Joyce will be able to see the screen
right on his presentation good can you
hear his choice
great well just to just uh like an intro
um
um Mickey will be giving his talk on uh
de elephants have names and then that's
uh Joyce Poole who's the voice of God
um in the background there who will um
there'll be a little bit of dialogue and
maybe some conversation afterwards so
just want to set everybody up
um go for it thank you cool thank you um
so for those of you who I haven't met
yet um I'm Mickey I'm a postdoc at
Colorado State University uh and I work
with uh with George Whitmire
um on elephants
so
um one of the fundamental components of
human language is vocal labeling which
I'm defining as using a learned sound to
refer to an object or individual and the
reason I say learned is because learning
is one of the things that gives our
vocal labeling as humans such
flexibility because we're not limited to
communicating about a set series of
topics that can be a Navy programmed so
this type of vocal labeling where you
learn a sound and use it to refer to an
object or individual is extremely rare
in the animal kingdom as far as we know
um there are very few animals that have
been demonstrated to do something like
that one exception of course is
bottlenose dolphins
um which uh as Diana talked about
yesterday can imitate the unique
signature whistle of another dolphin in
order to address them which is
effectively calling one another by name
but one important difference between
naming via imitation of the Target and
the type of vocal labeling that's common
in human language is that naming via
imitation inherently limits
communication to things that make a
sound that can be imitated and an
important an important feature of human
words is that their arbitrary and
structure meaning that they're not
derived from the sounds made by the the
thing that they refer to
um nor from any other properties of that
sound in other words they're not iconic
they're arbitrary and um of course
Dolphins can learn arbitrary labels for
artificial objects in captivity but we
don't know if they use this capability
in the wild
so
um while signature whistles themselves
are arbitrary in their structure in that
they're not they're not iconically
connected to the identity of the dolphin
who makes the signature whistle when
they're used in the context of
addressing another individual I would
argue that they're not arbitrary labels
because they're they're labeling the the
referent the the labeling the receiver
by imitating the sounds that are
typically made by that receiver so if we
could find an example of learned
arbitrary names in a non-human species
this could have really important
implications for our understanding of
the evolution of language because it
would provide us with another case
um to compare with humans and try to
understand the selection pressures that
may have led to the evolution of this
rare ability in our own species and it
would also potentially
um blur the line somewhat between what
we think is uh unique to human language
versus what's found in other animal
communication systems
so that brings me to my study species
the African elephant so um elephants are
interesting from the perspective of
studying vocal communication and
potentially naming for a variety of
reasons so uh one they're often out of
sight of their family members when
communicating so it could be
particularly valuable for them to be
able to address one another by name more
importantly unlike other mammals
elephants in captivity are known to be
capable of learning to imitate and
produce novel sounds this is something
that is found in a few other mammal
species dolphins being one of them
humans being another but it's definitely
the exception rather than the rule among
mammals
and uh the most common type of call that
elephants produce is something called a
rumble which uh is is really I I always
like to use the analogy I think talking
about rumbles as a single call type is a
little bit like if an alien came down to
planet Earth and was interested in
studying human communication and they're
like okay we're gonna category we're
gonna catalog the human vocal repertoire
we've got screaming crying laughing
grunting and uh this other call called
speech and that seems to be the most
common one that they make I I think I
mean I'm not necessarily saying that
rumbles are speech but um but they're
analogous in the sense that rumbles are
the vast majority of calls made by
elephants and they're structurally
highly variable and produced in almost
every behavioral context so I think that
most of the interesting Communication in
elephants at least from my perspective
is happening in these rumbles and
rumbles are partially infrasonic so the
fundamental frequency at least of adult
elephants is typically in the infrasonic
range the higher harmonics are typically
audible to us
um I'm not sure if this will play but
let's see if
there we go so that's a that's a typical
uh Rumble sound
um so one type of Rumble that they make
is this contact Rumble which is uh a
call that's produced over long distances
um to communicate with family members
who are out of sight and then another
type of Rumble that they produce is a
greeting Rumble which happens when
um uh two individuals who've been
separated for some period of Time come
back into contact and Joyce further
splits greeting rumbles into two types
so um she categorizes them as either
greeting rumbles or little greeting
rumbles based on uh how how exuberant
the display is
um how long they've been separated that
kind of thing for the purposes of my
study I just lumped them together uh but
the these are basically just defined as
calls produced when elephants are
engage in an affiliative interaction
after some period of Separation
um
so um we set out to answer the the
following questions in this study
um so one do elephant calls contain
acoustic variation that's specific to
individual receivers um so that's kind
of the first step in determining if
elephants have names
um do these calls even have information
that is specific to individual receivers
number two if these calls do have
information that's potentially a name do
different callers use the same name for
a given receiver or does every caller
use their own name for a given receiver
three are these names if they exist
imitations of the receivers calls in the
way that bottom those Dolphins uh names
are imitations of the receiver's
signature whistle or are they arbitrary
they're unrelated to the sounds made by
the receiver and finally do elephants
preferentially respond to their own name
this would sort of be the gold standard
to show that not only do the calls have
information that identifies the receiver
but the receivers actually pick up on
that information and understand it
so um I collected data in samburu
National Reserve in Northern Kenya and
also collaborated with Joyce to use her
data set that she collected in
ambasselli National Park in southern
Kenya and we identified individual
elephants by the ear shape so in both
the samburu and the ambasselli
populations these elephants have been
studied continuously for decades and we
know all the individuals in these Parks
um by the the unique shape of their ears
and tusks Etc
and so I recorded the the identity of
the caller the identity of the receiver
and the behavioral context of each call
when possible and I identified the
receiver using behavioral cues so for
example if we had a contact calling
situation where everybody in the family
is moving together and there's one
individual lagging behind then somebody
stops and turns toward the individual
who's lagging behind makes a long
distance call we can reasonably infer
that the individual she was calling to
is the one who's lagging behind because
everybody else was with her or similarly
if there's a greeting call between two
elephants and I know who made the call
then presumably the receiver is the
other one engaged in that greeting
interaction
so um I decided to only include contact
and greeting calls in this analysis
because they're the two contexts where I
think it's most likely that naming might
be occurring and it's also they were
also the two most common contexts for
which I was able to identify a single
receiver so in total we ended up with
625 contacting greeting rumbles from
samburu and amicelli
so again objective one is to determine
if the elephant calls have acoustic
features in them that are specific to
individual receivers so to do this first
I had to extract some features from the
calls and um we went back and forth on a
lot of different possible ways to do
this but what we end the approach we
ended up settling on is uh is sort of a
multi-step approach so we take the
spectrogram of the call which is on the
left
um and that's just a representation of
frequency on the y-axis time in the
x-axis and then the heat map represents
the the intensity or the amplitude and
then past that um past that call through
a mail filter bank which is a
psychoacoustic filter bank that's meant
to approximate the hearing sensitivity
of humans but it turns out it works
pretty well for other mammals too so
basically humans and other mammals
including elephants here uh we're better
at hearing the differences between low
frequencies than hearing the differences
between high frequencies so this filter
Bank increases with width as you go up
in frequency so it's kind of blurring
higher frequencies together while
providing greater discrimination between
lower frequencies and then you end after
passing the call through the mail filter
rank the Mel filter Bank you get a Mel
spectrogram which is this sort of
blurred spectrogram that's
um warped to the the acoustic perception
of humans and to a lesser extent
elephants and then so this this Mel
spectrogram has uh 26 bands in it 26
frequency bands and for each band I took
as the first raw feature the just the
vector of energies in that band then I
calculated from that Vector of energies
the Delta coefficients which are the the
differences between successive energy
values and then the Delta Delta
coefficients which is the differences
between successive Delta values so
essentially what this is measuring is
the the Contour of energy in a
particular frequency in particular male
frequency band the
um the rate of change of that energy
over time and then the acceleration of
that energy over time
um and then I also measure the uh
Hilbert amplitude envelope of each call
so in total ended up with 79 raw
acoustic Contours for each call but each
of these
each of these matrices of 79 Contours is
going to be a different size for every
call because the call is different in
duration so in order to turn them into
features that could be used in a
statistical model I stacked all the
calls end to end ran a robust principal
component analysis on it which basically
decomposes the data into a low rank
Matrix that's
um the sort of the well so so there's
decomposes it into a low rank Matrix and
a sparse Matrix the sparse Matrix
essentially represents outliers and the
low rank Matrix represents the principal
components of the data that are not
outliers and you set your threshold for
outliers with a parameter called Lambda
and then took this um robot this uh
these robust principle components
calculated the means of the first 74
which were the the number required to
explain 99.9 of the variation we also
calculated 16 different measures of the
the the modes of modulation in the
principal components themselves
um and I can go into that in more detail
if you'd like but suffice it to say it's
just describing how the principal
components change over time essentially
um and then also some four summary
statistics from the sparse Matrix as
well just in case the outliers mattered
so so we we essentially took the calls
and through this this step of multi-step
process turned them into a series of
features that could be put into a
statistical model they're they're a
little bit uninterpretable but um we
chose these features because we thought
that they would describe the the
relevant variation in the calls
uh and then I took these features and
put them into a random forest model
um so I I imagine that most of you don't
need any introduction to random Forest
but for those who do essentially it's a
collection of decision trees where every
decision tree in the forest uses a
different subset of the data and it's
splitting the data at each at each
branching Point into uh um and so it
splits it more and more until it arrives
at some at some finishing point which is
uh where like all calls that are in the
same terminal Leaf are sort of
categorized together in the same
category and then you have this uh um
averaging procedure across all the trees
to come up with a single classification
for each observation in the data set so
I used 500 decision trees six acoustic
features per node in the tree
um and then 60 of all the observations
in the data set per tree yeah
try using this on human speech to see
what happens I have not no
um what would be the the idea to see
what sorts of features you have picked
out that people sort of have the answers
in fact right yeah that's a really
that's a really interesting idea um I I
didn't do that but that's definitely
worth thinking about
um okay so we have this random Forest
architecture and then the idea is that
we want to train on part of the data and
test on the remaining parts I use
six-fold cross validation so essentially
the data sets split into six equal size
components and we train on five of those
components test on the sixth and then do
that for all six folds so that the data
is trained and tested on all on the full
data set but not all at once
um and then average the results across
the across the folds
so in order so so this random Forest
will give us a classification accuracy
it will tell us what percent of these
calls were classified oh I I guess I I
forgot to mention the most important
part which is that the random Forest is
trying to classify the identity of the
receiver of a call as a function of the
acoustic features sorry about that that
was that was a key piece of information
um so essentially this random Forest is
going to tell us for uh what percentage
of these calls can be correctly
classified according to who the call was
addressed to so if the calls have some
information in them that's specific to
individual receivers you should be able
to predict the receiver from the
acoustic structure of the call but in
order to determine if that percentage
that the random virus predicts correctly
is better than random guessing we have
to have some uh null model for what you
would expect under random chance and
there are a few different ways to do
this
um the way that we chose is to run the
same mod model with the acoustic
features randomized so it's essentially
getting input data but the input data is
meaningless and then we did that 10 000
times and calculated the classification
accuracy each time and then generated a
distribution of these classification
accuracies with randomized features and
then we compared the original
classification accuracy from the model
with the real features to this
distribution of classification
accuracies produced using random
features and
um so this this gray histogram is the is
the null distribution and this red line
is the classification accuracy we got
with the original model so the original
model correctly predicted about 20.3
percent of the calls which is
significantly greater than what we got
with the the null distribution
um I I don't have the I don't have the
data here but I also tried using a
majority classifier where you just
always predict the most common receiver
and it also performs significantly
better than that
so um this suggests that these calls are
specific in individual receivers but
there's still some alternative
explanations so one big problem is that
in our data set caller ID and receiver
ID were correlated so certain callers
were far more likely to call to certain
receivers uh and vice versa
so it's possible that the model could
just be using caller specific features
that is like features that are
associated with the voice of the caller
and using those to predict the identity
of the receiver because caller and
receiver are are partially aliased in
its data set
um also another possibility is that
rather than being specific to
individuals the calls are specific to
Broad categories of relationships and
again because of this aliasing of caller
and receiver ID if the calls are say
specific to like Mom rather than a
particular individual and most and most
of the moms in the data set happen to be
a few individuals then it might guess
those individuals better than chance so
to rule out these two alternative
possibilities I did a couple things
first we categorized um the relationship
between each caller receiver pair using
these 11 categories which we based on on
our knowledge of elephant social
relationships this may not necessarily
be how elephants categorize their
relationships but it is at least based
on on their biology to a degree so
things like a mother calling to her
daughter
um daughter calling to her mother
individuals of roughly the same age
calling to each other individual and
somebody calling to an older female who
is most likely her aloe mother when she
was young that kind of thing so we've
categorized the relationships between
every possible pair of callers and
receivers in the data set and then we
calculated a random Forest proximity
score between each possible pair of
calls in the data set so the proximity
score is essentially a measure of
similarity between any two calls in
terms of the acoustic features that were
used by the model to predict receiver ID
and the way this is calculated is if you
look at all the decision trees in the
random Forest we take the of all the so
for any two calls so let's say call a
and call D or in this in this data set
each letter represents an individual
call in this figure
so let's say we take call a and call D
and we look at across all the trees what
percentage of trees in which both call a
and call D were included
um did those two calls appear in the
same terminal node of the decision Tree
in this example here you've got four
trees and a and d uh uh appear in the
same note the same terminal node and
three of them so the proximity score
would be 0.75 and we used
um a a more recent formulation of random
Forest proximity scores that account for
the difference in size between nodes
um so uh so it's just basically
discounts this in terms of the the
probability of a call ending up in a
particular node in the first place so
again the important thing is that this
is just a measure of similarity between
any two calls and then
uh we ran an anova to look at the mean
proximity score as a function of
um web of
the particular type of pair that we're
looking at so so each pair of calls
could be categorized we we took all that
we we only looked at the pairs of calls
where
um they were produced by the same caller
both calls were produced by the same
caller so these calls could either be
categorized as
um both call both callers in a given
pair uh were addressing the same is both
both calls in a given pair were from the
same caller addressing the same receiver
or both calls in a given pair were from
the same caller but addressing two
different receivers who had the same
type of relationship to that caller so
here we're explicitly controlling for
caller ID and for the type of
relationship between the caller and the
receiver
and we found that pairs of calls with
the same caller and the same individual
receiver had significantly higher
proximity scores than pairs of calls
that had the same caller addressing two
different receivers with the same type
of relationship to them so this suggests
that the calls are not
um the calls are not specific just two
different categories of relationship but
they're specific to individual receivers
and also that um
the model was not just using caller ID
to predict receiver ID because even when
you hold caller ID constant you're still
get calls from the same caller to the
same receiver are still more similar
than calls from the same caller to
different receivers
so for objective two whether different
callers use the same name to address a
given receiver
um we we had two predictions number one
a random Forest trained with calls from
one set of callers should be able to
predict receiver ID in um calls made by
a different set of callers yeah so I'm
think I got a little lost somewhere in
the first objective so is it right to
say that you did some feature extraction
in a fairly unsupervised way random
forced all of that but okay you got some
features out and then you wanted to
explore whether these features were
relevant to the hypotheses that you were
posing so once you have your features
you can test proximity between calls in
the future space and then you in in
objective number one you checked whether
the relationship type was significant
that was only part of it so objective
number one was to determine if the calls
contain information that's specific to
an individual receiver okay so we showed
that the call we show that you can
predict the receiver better than chance
from the acoustic structure of the call
but in order to rule out the possibility
that the model was actually using caller
specific features rather than receiver
specific features we held caller ID
constant with the proximate midi score
analysis and then we also controlled for
the relationship type so that way we
know that the calls are specific to
individual receivers not just to Broad
categories of receivers and also that
it's not just that the model is using
the correlation between caller ID and
receiver ID to predict receiver ID even
when you hold call ID constant the calls
are still specific to individual
receivers
that makes sense yeah okay cool
um so so number one if if different
callers use the same name for the same
receiver then um a random par is trained
with one set of callers should be able
to predict receivers in a different set
of callers if the the receivers are the
same across the sets of callers and then
two uh calls with different callers
addressing the same receiver should be
more similar than calls with different
callers addressing different receivers
so we found mixed support for this idea
so in the random Forest we trained a
random Forest
um using uh using training and test
splits such that the saint all calls
from a given caller receiver pair were
always in the same fold so the model was
never tested on the same callers that it
was trained on and when we did this it
performed no better than a random model
so so essentially we found no evidence
that the model could predict receiver ID
um when it was trained on a different
set of callers than it was tested on but
when we looked at the proximity scores
um calls I don't know why this thing is
it's been popping up like
it's it's weird because I can't see I
don't see it on my on my screen I only
see it on the
so annoying
I don't know how to make it go away
oh oh there's okay there's the curse we
gotcha
so uh
all right um
I don't know why it's not showing on my
screen now but but anyway
um basically when we
uh when so the random forest was not
able to predict receiver ID across
callers but
um calls from different callers to the
same receiver were significantly more
similar in their proximity scores than
uh calls from different callers to
different receivers so to me this
suggests that most likely there is some
convergence among callers when
addressing the same receiver but they're
not converging completely
um or there's just additional variation
in those calls that we're not able to to
parse out because we don't know which
what variation in the calls is important
for encoding receiver ID and what
variation is used to encode other
information
so um
okay I think I may need some technical
assistance to get back to the
presentation because
it's not it's not showing the slides
when I click over
well answer your question yeah
did you get a proximity score for the
same like the call against its identical
self I'm just trying to figure out the
effect size I get this um
no I don't think
you can calculate a proximity score for
the call against itself because the
proximity score is is yeah thank you
it's calculated as in terms of how often
they appear in the same terminal node
together yeah
um
but yeah that's a good question just
trying to understand the y-axis
uh yeah so the the it's it's so these
we're only looking here at pairs of
calls that had different callers
um and either they had different callers
addressing the same receiver or they had
different callers addressing different
receivers and then so the two calls in a
given pair are always two different
calls and in this analysis they always
had different colors yeah I'm sorry
could you explain the graph on the left
again sure so so the graph on the left
the gray histogram represents the
distribution of classification
accuracies with random acoustic features
and the red line represents the
classification accuracy with the real
acoustic features so it's it's basically
smack in the middle of that distribution
so it was it was not any better than
than a random no model
so um objective three are these calls
imitations of the receivers calls or are
they um are they arbitrary are they
unrelated to the sounds made by the
receiver
so um in order to do that we assessed if
the calls were quote unquote imitations
of the receivers calls by classifying
each call as either conversion or
Divergent relative to the receiver's
calls so convergent calls were more
similar to the receivers calls than
typical for that caller unless you
um again using uh using proximity scores
as a measure of similarity and Divergent
calls were less similar to the
receiver's calls than typical for that
caller using proximity scores as a
measure of similarity so if elephant
calls are imitations of the receiver's
calls then we would expect that the
random Forest would only be able to
correctly predict receiver ID for the
convergent calls but not for the
Divergent calls
but that's not what we found at all we
found when we looked at the results of
the random forest for just the the
convergent call like just looked at the
predictions of the random Forest among
just the convergent calls versus just
the Divergent calls in both cases it was
significantly better than the null
expectation so this suggests that it
doesn't really matter if the calls are
convergent on the receiver's calls or
Divergent from the receiver's calls
relative to what's typical for that
caller the random Forest is still
correctly predicting receiver ID from
the acoustic structure of the call
and finally the last objective was to
determine if these putative names in the
calls are actually meaningful to the
elephants so to do that I did a playback
experiment
where I played back two contact calls
each to 17 subjects so each subject
received two different playbacks on
different days
um one playback was a contact call that
was originally addressed to the subject
herself and the other was a contact call
from the same caller that was originally
addressed to somebody else so the idea
is that if receivers react more strongly
to their own name they should react more
strongly more quickly call more in
response to calls that were originally
addressed to them relative to calls from
the same caller that were not originally
addressed to them so we're controlling
for call type by only using contact
calls we're controlling for the identity
of the caller by using tests and control
calls from the same caller so the only
difference here is who the call was
originally addressed to and
um we predicted that they would react
more quickly and call more in response
to call that were originally addressed
to them and that's exactly what we found
so we found that subjects approach to
the speaker significantly more quickly
in response to playback of calls that
were originally addressed to them
compared to playback of calls that were
originally addressed to someone else we
also found that they vocalized more
quickly in response to calls that were
originally addressed to them and finally
we found that they produced more calls
on average after playback of calls that
were originally addressed to them
doing
um so I think elephants are just kind of
slow in general they're they they take
their sweet time about things and they
don't necessarily react on the same kind
of immediate time frame that we do
um so I measure the latency over 10
minutes that may have been excessive I
don't know
um but often we would see a reaction
after several seconds
or
I mean heart rate would be really
interesting but I think the challenge is
that to put any kind of tag on an
elephant you need to immobilize them
which is huge yeah a huge operation
um eye tracking could be done but I
think it would be very hard to do in the
wild because there's just so much
interference from the light levels and
shadows and the elephants moving around
and you can't get super close to them so
usually in in playback experiments with
wild animals you use more obvious things
like with primates they often use where
they turn their head but with elephants
they don't have the same degree
binocular vision as a primate so them
turning and they're also they also don't
depend on eyesight as much as we do so
turning their head isn't necessarily as
big of a tell
um I also measure things like uh
vigilance I don't show this here but I
didn't find any difference with
vigilance but again it's hard to it's a
little bit hard to measure visual
vigilance objectively because well like
if they're raising their head and when
exactly they're endowed you know they're
kind of lowering it slowly so I don't
know but um we the the differences we
found were in the latency to to approach
the latency to vocalize and then in the
number of localizations
is there another question
um okay so in conclusion we found
evidence one that calls are specific to
individual receivers and most likely not
just to Broad categories of receivers
um we've also found evidence that
different callers use somewhat similar
but definitely not identical calls for
the same receiver
we found evidence that receiver
specificity is likely not contingent on
imitation of the receiver's calls which
suggests that the names are likely
arbitrary in structure and finally we
found that receivers can determine if a
call was addressed to them just from the
acoustic structure of the call alone
um so I think there are some interesting
implications of this which is one as far
as I know it's the first evidence for uh
for wild animals use um addressing one
another using uh essentially arbitrary
labels
um two it suggests an Adaptive function
for vocal learning in elephants which
until now we hadn't we didn't have any
empirical evidence that suggested
anything about why elephants have this
ability to learn new sounds in captivity
now there's some there's some reason to
believe that perhaps they're using their
vocal learning ability to learn uh names
for one another
um and this could speculatively
speculatively this could be a reason why
other taxa have evolved vocal learning
too so there's a lot of a lot of animals
that um have vocal learning that don't
uh don't use it to produce complex
sexually selected song but they all live
in complex fission fusion societies
where it might be advantageous to
address individuals by name and there's
some evidence in parrots for example
which are also excellent vocal Learners
um that they that they can address one
another by name too
um and then finally there's some
interesting cognitive implications For
Elephants here
um
so uh just quickly I don't know how much
how much time I have left but
like maybe five minutes and then bring
to it okay yeah that sounds good um so I
just wanted to talk a little bit about
where I'd like to take this in the
future
um if I can get you know assuming I can
get funding and everything to continue
the project
um so one thing I would really like to
know is how these names are encoded in
the rumbles and I think the biggest
limiting factor here is the imbalance in
our data set or caller ID and receiver
ID were correlated so what I'd like to
do is just intensively record from one
family so we can get a more balanced
data set with calls from all the callers
addressing all the potential receivers
and then retrain a machine learning
model using this balance data so that we
can implicitly control for caller ID in
that model and then identify the calls
that are consistently classified
correctly across model iterations and
then and then try and ultimately
synthesize names so we can isolate the
particular features that encode them and
I there's a few different ways you might
do this one we might use more
interpretable features and use something
as simple as a nominal logistic
regression to just see which features
come out as significant predictors of
receiver ID another possibility
something more a bit more sophisticated
like again to try and generate uh names
for particular individuals
um
I think it would also be fascinating to
know if uh if we can identify these
names and isolate them
um to know if elephants are using names
to talk about other individuals in their
absence which would be really
interesting because this would be an
example of displacement talking about
something that's not currently there
um and first we obviously have to
reliably identify the names in the first
place and then finally um it would be
very interesting to know if elephants
use vocal labeling or naming outside of
the context of personal names for
individuals for example they might use
names to refer to places so when
elephants are deciding where to go as a
group often there's some some vocal
exchanges and maybe Joyce can talk about
this a little bit but um there there's
the possibility that perhaps these vocal
exchanges are negotiations about where
to go next and by combining uh
recordings of these vocal exchanges with
machine learning and GPS tracking or
just following the elephants in a
vehicle we could potentially determine
if they're labeling places as well as
individuals
um and so I just like to thank my
collaborators and and funders and uh I
think we'll turn it over to conversation
with Joyce
foreign
we probably have a lot of questions but
maybe um can we beam joyson
hi let's see there you are all right
yeah we'll pass it to you first and then
we'll open it up to the team
yeah it's it's so exciting
titles
um you know watching elephants for all
these years and it's so clear sometimes
when you know they're in a group and and
some will give a contact call and one
individual will answer and nobody else
pays any attention and then the same
individual will give another contact
call and a different individual answers
or in the case of of Greetings or little
greetings uh similar sort of thing that
it and I always felt that they were
directing these calls to specific
individuals so it's it's just so
exciting after all these years to to
um to be able to collaborate with Mickey
and and to to come up with these
exciting results maybe
um would you mind sharing with group
some of your your background of your of
your life's work and uh and uh and and
and foreign
just a brief overview yeah
um well I mean both both Mickey and I
are really fortunate to be
associated with projects uh very
long-term projects on on individual
individually known elephants
um the project that I've been associated
with is the ambicelli elephant research
project that was started by Cynthia moss
in 1972 And I joined in in 1975.
um so you know it's in its 51st year and
has followed the lives and deaths I
guess no the lives anyway of of 3 900
elephants there are
1800 elephants alive today
um living in 63 families
um and there are now 23 elephants still
alive
today
um who were alive at the beginning of
the project were born in 1972 or before
four males and 19 females so having I
mean and and in the case of Mickey I
think it's something like 30 30 years
isn't it Mickey from the yeah I I think
I don't remember the exact year I think
they started in 1997 something like that
in 1990
oh yeah you're right I think it may may
be that
yeah
um so in fact it and in fact it's
interesting because both Cynthia and Ian
um well Cynthia got her start on
elephants working on Ian's uh assisting
Ian on his PhD work and and helped to
set up the whole photographic individual
photographic uh recognition system that
both of these projects use and also the
you know the the the the the method for
collecting the sightings records
um and and you know the monitoring in in
general
so um we I mean you know you can't do
this kind of work without these very
very long-term studies on individually
known
um animals especially with elephant
Animals As Long lived as as elephants
um I started uh I mean I was studying
male reproductive behavior and then got
very interested in in the fact that the
males when they were threatening me were
making a sound that I could barely hear
and that didn't make much sense to me
and um turned out that you know most of
the most of the rumble was infrasonic
and that put me in touch with Katie
Payne and we started working together
um and Katie then began the elephant
listening project so that's another very
long-term term study then on on Forest
elephants so there'd been a a kind of a
in a way a small group of us that have
um spawned these very long-term projects
which are are going to be so valuable
when it comes to to
um the work we have ahead which is to
use you know AI to try and understand
these animals better
thank you I'll open it up to the team
any questions from here
foreign
I just would like to know how much you
personally can differentiate between the
different calls or is there something
where you where you suddenly recognize
or immediately recognize this is that
individual's name is being called
um so I personally cannot differentiate
between them at all in terms of
identifying who they're addressing
the only way I can have any idea who
they're addressing is from behavioral
cues um Joyce has a lot more experience
than me I don't I don't know do you have
any inkling from a call of who the
intended receiver is just from hearing
the structure
well by the type of call you know by the
type of Rumble then one can guess who
they're who they're referring to or who
they're talking to but if it's just
um the the greeting rumbles and the
contact calls no
um it's it is based on on the behavior
one of the things that I I really use
when
um you know you're talking about you
know who who is the receiver is the the
response of the animal that that head
lifting and the way the ears are lifted
um is is typically you know the animal
that's being you know the receiver
um so but it's it's pretty in a way it
can be kind of quite subtle
[Music]
yeah we do so we I mean we have a
numbering system in samburu
um but but we no no no
um I mean we we're we're our goal is is
to
um to interact with them as little as
possible where basically they're
habituated to humans in vehicles but we
want them to treat us as a feature of
the landscape we don't want them to be
altering their behavior because of our
presence
in different capacities and presumably
um
[Music]
attentive to those names at all or as
far as I know yes I mean from from what
I understand you know I've never worked
with cap developments but
um from what I understand
um they're they're capable of learning
not just their names but quite a large
vocabulary of of commands but but again
you know these are wild elephants no not
domestic elephants so we're we're not
trying to to call them or anything we're
I mean we have Nate we have numbers for
them and also names for them but that's
that's just so we can identify who they
are yeah
hi uh Joyce
um amazing work and obviously
um it's really an honor to speak to you
my name's Shane I'm I'm the sperm whale
biologist on Project study
um and so uh Mickey I have questions for
you too but I can catch you after this
sure yeah because they're more specific
to your talk but I I was wondering with
with all of these amazing computer
scientists in the room if you could sort
of think about after spending so much
time in the company of animals uh
elephants you know where you think the
computer scientists can come in and
support sort of the questions you never
thought you'd be able to answer or the
questions that you know are answerable
but require a new approach because I
think that would be that'd be really
fascinating
foreign
I think that you know the one that
Mickey talked about whether elephants
have place names because you know every
every day in their lives
um these are families that like ours are
are splitting apart and coming back
together again making making plans about
where they're gonna go each day and they
use uh what I call a let's go Rumble
where they they they use the axis of
their body to point the direction they
want to go they use a lot of intention
movements along and give this very
particular Rumble
um that's very distinctive uh and look
back to see whether members of their
family are following them or not so
um and and they'll have they can go on
calling for quite a long period of time
and then
um and then if the others don't come
they can go into what what I call
Cadence drumbling where there's this
back and forth conversation that I've
recorded up you know up to like half an
hour and sometimes they will agree on
something and it seems to be some sort
of negotiation and then they'll
sometimes they'll go their separate ways
they'll just finally give up trying to
agree on something but
um I do think that it's quite likely
that they you know they can refer to
whether it's whether it's a direction or
whether it's an actual place name
but but
um I think that's that would be very
fruitful the other thing that
um
uh working in gorongosa uh where where
we worked from 20 what was it 2011 to
2019 uh very aggressive elephants and we
had we were off in charged but uh this
was often group group charges where the
animals Had Each family like had
different traditions in the way they
they would try to
um attack us and and I just found that
the the the complexity of the
communication that was going on was just
I mean it was just amazing I don't know
how you would study it but or even
record it but it seemed to me that there
were very clear instructions being given
um and that that you know families knew
exactly or the individuals of their
family knew exactly where they were
supposed to be and how they were uh
supposed to respond to us
foreign
thank you
yep yeah hi Katie it's Diana Reese great
to see you again and I had a Joyce what
did I just say I'm sorry and
um I Michael I just had a question for
you both of you actually so have you
looked at the calls of younger animals
as well I don't know if you included
this in your database and whether the
mothers calls uh the if it's a mother or
it's another animal do their calls
change at all of her time I don't know
if you've you've taken a look at that at
all just wondering about that they do
change every time
um in fact they're they're calls the
calls the calls that
um mothers give to calves and the calf
responses
um I think develop over time into little
greeting rumbles so Mickey mentioned
that
um you mentioned aloe mothers making
um or or individuals who you thought
might have been aloe mothers to the the
receiver or something when they were
younger
and I you know I think that these very
close relationships between aloe mothers
and and the Cubs
um when they're adults are are are
likely to be the ones that have these
close uh little greeting Rumble uh calls
between one another
thank you
I remember correctly from my
few readings on elephants with the
couple of readings I wrote down on
elephants I understand that they
communicate or they use their highly
olfactory animals and they saw smell and
vibration it's also something that they
use is there a way to add some of that
data at least vibration to the to the
sounds that you're picking up to try to
complement the data that you're using to
identify the names and how they called
each other out so um the the vibratory
stuff has mostly been studied by Caitlin
O'Connell Rodwell in um in Namibia but
there's also some people who are
starting to to do some work on vibratory
communication at my field site in
samburu
um so in order to record that you need
to put like a special you need to bury a
special device in the ground in order to
to record those rumbles so it's
definitely possible to record them but
the disadvantage is that you you need to
predict where the elephants are going to
be because you can't just move it around
very easily
um so it Caitlyn's field site she has
like this observation tower at a
watering hole so she knows elephants are
going to come there eventually she can
just set up the the
vibration recorder ahead of time
um it's samburu I think it's probably
more challenging because you have to I
mean they have done some work there with
the vibratory communication but you have
to kind of predict where the elephants
are going to be and then
um know that they're going to call all
and put the bury the thing in the ground
um so yeah you can definitely do it but
in terms of getting like a large volume
of recordings it does make it a little
bit more logistically challenging and
with olfactory communication I think
um this is actually something I was
wondering if I I know nothing about
robotics but
um like a lot of narrow Factory
Communications through temporal plans
secretions on the side of their head
which obviously you can't collect from a
wild elephant unless you've immobilized
them but I don't know just like total
speculation I wonder if it's possible to
build some kind of minuscule drone that
would mimic a fly and just land on their
head and suck up some Timber and
solution
yeah thank you very much for uh for the
talk uh I'm a roboticist that makes
little flies
no but I I was before you said that
though I was just curious if you could
speculate either of your or both of you
can speculate on uh data collection
needs you kind of were alluding to this
when you're talking about O'Connell's
work phones but I'm just curious you
know if you had your pie in the sky wish
list what would you have for data
collection devices
I have so many things but Choice do you
want to you want to start
I just I just hate the idea that we have
to immobilize elephants it's so
traumatic for the family and you know
they're sometimes elephants have been
lost
um and and sometimes callers have gone
on and not been taken off and which and
elephants continue to grow so anyway it
would be absolutely fantastic to be able
to
uh maybe for shorter periods of time but
to have a family let's say that we're
following really closely and be able to
put recording devices on each individual
but you know not via caller but but a
very small robotic device
yeah I think um to just add to that uh I
think anything that could record from
the elephants with in a non-invasive way
continuously
um would be hugely helpful but also like
maybe slightly less Pie in the Sky idea
having like having an acoustic camera
that is portable enough to carry around
in a Jeep and could um could pinpoint
the location of sound because just
identifying the collar for Elephants is
is challenging and we miss a lot of
calls that way because we just can't
figure out who made them so having an
acoustic camera that's recording
continuous video and audio and can
pinpoint in the video which elephant is
making the sound
um that would be that would be hugely
helpful as well
I used I had one with some Japanese
filmmakers came years ago they had a
camera that was used for uh detecting
where low frequency sound was coming
from in a in a city
and they they uh followed actually it
was a it was all this Cadence calling or
there was a discussion going on between
uh Enid and Echo about where they were
going to go and and there was this
calling back and forth and you could see
which you know very clearly which
elephant was called oh oh that's
incredible yeah I didn't know the
commercial things would work that well
but
hi
um so do you have a for both of you do
you have a kind of a
where would you place the range of like
complexity of what their discourse might
be about
um most between like what is the most
complex you think it might be and what
is the least complex now that you know
that they have uh naming
Choice then do you want to talk about
that I can narrow it down a bit if
that's how but
I don't know you know these are they're
complex animals living
very
uh
in a very complex social system and
which they navigate so well I mean it's
it's
I've always thought that that it's much
more what they're saying to one another
is much more
um
yeah sorry keep using the word complex
but complex then then we we imagine
um you know some of the things like for
instance there's so much of their of
their rather complex uh behavior that
we're just where they're really
vocalizing a lot that we can't make head
or tail of because they all talk talk on
top of one another
and during the like a greeting ceremony
um
uh you know you can have you know you
could have 30 elephants all vocalizing
together and all producing
structurally different looking rumbles
and trumpets and Roars and everything at
the same time so uh is it just a lot of
exuberance and you like we have when we
greet one another or is there something
more
uh going on not just it's great to be
together again but you know and what are
we gonna do now and you know what's been
your experiences since we've been apart
but some of these greetings go can go on
for
you know five minutes of rumbling
great well thank thank you both for um
such a fascinating talk and I know here
at uh project City where we're we're
maniacally focused on on whales but
we're we're really interested in
transcending our work in service of the
whales and in service of animals like
like elephants so we're we're excited to
explore our synergies on
um you know where there could be
crossover
um in studying these these magnificent
animals so um thank you thank you both
thank you
excuse me